this video is sponsored by Squarespace
huge thanks to those guys for supporting
the channel powerlifting and kettlebell
training are such a great pairing that I
think literally anyone who does one of
these training modalities could benefit
from at least dabbling in the other now
to be clear I'm not saying this is the
perfect way that everyone should be
training in fact I'm not really much of
a power lifter myself so all I'm really
saying is that combining two different
training modalities is a great way to
start getting more variety in your
training and to cover a more
comprehensive training profile and for
that reason kettlebell training
powerlifting is just another combination
that works so well together I think a
lot of people could benefit from let's
start with powerlifting powerlifting is
fantastic for building raw max strength
and this translates to a lot of other
aspects of performance this is why a lot
of people consider powerlifting and the
big three lifts to be one of the best
things you can do if you want to improve
your overall Sports Performance strength
Fitness Etc it can improve mobility in
certain areas it can help to make you
more resilient against injury for things
like bending over and picking things up
off the ground and it's fantastic for
building bone density core strength and
you get some hypertrophy in there as
well if you're interested in building
muscle it just makes really big powerful
people
what powerlifting isn't so good for
though on the other hand is variety
powerlifting is very much linear it's
very much in the sagittal plane up and
down up and down three lifts with a few
accessories potentially this won't give
you the full range of benefits that you
can get from something like functional
training say you're not moving at all in
the frontal plane you never move side to
side against resistance you never move
in the transverse plane the rotational
plane you're not talking the hips or the
waist and this is a big emission because
this is something that you really need
in everyday life whether it's wrestling
whether it's moving furniture all the
examples I give all the time even
throwing even running twisting the body
is actually how we generate power an
awful lot of the time powerlifting also
doesn't do much for your work capacity
or your endurance if you're doing a lot
of Max lifts or you know three to four
reps to focus on building strength then
you aren't going to be getting that
cardio now some people have argued that
if you train with a really heavy weight
then you're going to be able to do more
repetitions of a lighter weight and
therefore you don't need work capacity
specific training you don't need cardio
and while there's an element of truth in
this it changes when we're talking about
things like 100 reps of push-ups and
whilst that might sound extreme this is
something that's a little bit more
similar to say wrestling or sparring or
doing a day's manual labor and in terms
of cardio and systemic endurance there's
really no arguing that power lifting is
particularly good for that
if you want to be a long distance Runner
and play any kind of sport so even go up
the stairs without getting out of breath
then just doing powerlifting just
getting heavier and heavier and focusing
on just a few repetitions it's just not
going to cut it so you need to combine
this with strength endurance and work
capacity if you want to be able to exert
that force that power for a longer
period of time powerlifting also lacks
things like single leg strength and
balance and mobility in some other areas
and whilst people don't like to hear
that their chosen training modality has
flaws or doesn't cover everything this
is just the reality
well training on the other hand is
fantastic in pretty much all the ways
that powerlifting isn't and lacks all
the things that powerlitting offers so
kettlebell training let's start with the
negative this time it's not so good for
building really big tree trunk legs
because normally with a kettlebell
you're going to be working with you know
20 30 40 50 kilograms maybe you can get
heavier kettlebells but they're really
rare and the way you use them is a
little bit different you're not going to
be focusing on that max strength for
kettlebell trading just doesn't cut it
for building max strength it's not ideal
for hypertrophy either it's harder to
build lots of muscle definition or big
biceps because again you're working with
these lighter weights and those weights
are performed in very compound very
explosive very swingy emotions that
aren't ideal for isolation or causing
muscle damage or causing metabolic
stress but where kettlebell training is
fantastic of course is that it does
build work capacity and it does build
strength endurance because you're using
it for longer rep ranges something like
a kettlebell swing you can do for 50 to
100 repetitions because it has this
circular motion it actually really lends
itself to that kind of training and the
same goes for many of the other
exercises whether it's Halos whether
it's Atlas swings or anything like that
at the same time catapult training is
also perfect for training in the
transverse plane the rotational plane
because you can do things like the atlas
swing like the Halos we are twisting the
body or twisting the arms or twisting
the hips
likewise there's plenty of movements in
the frontal plane with kettlebells for
example you can do like a deep Cossack
squat it's also brilliant for building
core strength and stability in all the
ways that are missing from power lifting
something like a Turkish getup is
brilliant for building shoulder Mobility
shoulder stability and it's fantastic
for building real Core Power and you're
moving through all these different
unusual ranges of motion and there's
plenty of single leg trading you can do
with kettlebells whether it's Bulgarian
split squats whether it's pistol squats
or something like that of course the
other thing that you don't get as much
from powerlifting is explosiveness and
rate of force production because with
powerlifting as I've discussed before
you're grinding through a really heavy
repetition so because the weight the
resistance is so great you can't move
that quickly meaning that you're not
building explosive power kettlebell
training a lot of the movements are very
explosive or ballistic to be more
precise and with something like the
kettlebell swing not only are you
learning to exert that Force really
powerfully and quickly also learning to
switch rapidly between explosive power
output and then total body relaxation
things that can really benefit a power
lifter
and at the same time kettlebell training
does offer some of the same benefits as
power lifting so for example
powerlifting is fantastic for grip
strength so is kettlebell training power
lifting because you have to grip onto
the bar and lift this really big heavy
thing for several repetitions kettlebell
training because you need the endurance
to grip onto something for a long time
that's moving and trying to get away
from you so in other words they merge
perfectly together if you combine
powerlifting with kettlebell training
you'll get lots of benefits that are
missing from each of them and you're
going to combine them to create
something really far more comprehensive
you'll have that strength and power and
those massive legs and be able to move
around like a tank but at the same time
you also have power and explosiveness in
the rotational plane and you'll be able
to use that strength for a long period
of time without getting out of breath
the people have enjoyed me talking about
combining modalities in the past but the
criticism I've had is that I haven't
provided an actual program well you can
see that up on the screen for this now
it's actually the easiest thing to
combine because powerlifting you can
simply do the big three lifts for you
know three sets of four repetitions or
whatever you like on each one a few
warm-up sets as well and you can do that
say twice a week then you can do the
catalog training twice a week and here
we're just going to focus on all the
things that are missing so we're going
to do high repetition kettlebell swings
to build up some of that work capacity
we're going to do Atma swings for more
work capacity but also for building that
core rotational power we're going to do
some Halos for building shoulder
strength then more rotation and we're
going to be doing some tuckish get-ups
as well for all the benefits that brings
a couple of things in the frontal plane
such as Costa squats and maybe something
for a single leg strength whether you
want to do a Bulgarian split squat or a
pistol squat
so there you go guys that's another
training recommendation that I highly
recommend let me know in the comments
down below what you think is this a good
pairing and what other two training
modalities do you think are particularly
well together and maybe I'll make a
video on them if I think there's enough
to discuss there if you want to try a
training program that combines not only
power lifting type moves and kettlebell
training but a whole bunch of other
stuff as well then check out my ebook
and training program super functional
training 2.0 that is a 80 plus page
ebook as well as over two hours of
instructional video and a complete
program that's suitable for any level
and for any kind of equipment highly
adaptable that'll be in the description
down below either way thank you so much
for watching this one guys and I'll see
you next time bye for now
whichever your chosen training modality
perhaps you want to share your passion
with the world in which case Squarespace
is a fantastic option and also happens
to be today's sponsor so Squarespace is
a platform that allows you to build
websites extremely easily it's a fully
functional Suite of tools used by some
of the biggest brands on the net and you
can get a website up and running in
literal minutes you've got easy content
creation and Publishing you can schedule
publishing there's Community aspects you
can email specific members you can look
at your metrics and track which pages
are being more successful or not as
fully integrated commenting which
supports threaded comments and much more
member management social media
integration if you want to post your
social posts directly to your site
there's members only areas and
e-commerce support for selling products
from your site there's tons and tons of
plugins so even if the wide range of
tools that you already have at your
disposal don't provide everything you
need you can get them elsewhere this is
great for e-commerce for example where
you can add things like global tracking
for orders whatever you can think of you
can build it with Squarespace head to
squarespace.com for your free trial and
when you're ready to launch bioneer
viewers can get 10 off their first
website or domain by going to
squarespace.com forward slash bioneer